the end of batman the dark knight right
the dark knight arises right howard it
sort of implied that your character
was either going to be robin to batman
right or maybe even in some way become
batman right because that's what it led
us to believe yeah and now they just
announced that um uh ben affleck's gonna
be batman that's right
was there some sort of notion that you
would be the next batman i think you
could be a good batman
thanks well that's a huge compliment
thank you very much and i'm a big batman
fan are you me too i love that huge big
comic book guy so you
was there any discussion about you being
the next batman there wasn't no and and
you know
chris nolan directed a trilogy his plan
was always to have three movies he said
very specifically the dark knight rises
will be the third and final
story of this trilogy that i'm making
right and uh and i think it's a really
good ending because it talks about it
throughout you know that batman is more
than a man and it's a symbol and we all
have a hero within us and yeah so to
have us uh somebody else
in the bat cave
at the end of that trilogy not bruce
wayne i think it's a really cool
ending so so were you kind of shocked
when they chose ben affleck uh because
maybe you thought somewhere along the
line you'd get the offer no i was not
because
you know like i said it's it's a story
that's
that chris nolan
told with those three movies right so i
wasn't expecting the next time batman
showed up
it to be part of that chris nolan story
you know